[Musica]
berlino ti ricordi ormai 62 giocattoli
se volete per limiti qui vieni andiamo
controllare sembra di sì
[Musica]
non aprire
tra le hai messo a tu questa scatola qua
[Musica]
stai facendo
vorrei che cosa ho trovato al piano di
sopra una scatola con scritto non aprire
forse è meglio non aprirla vero ma sarà
piena di cibo allora non lo so fi che in
questa casa succedono tantissime cose
strane io non vorrei che spuntate fuori
qualche mostro da qua dentro
io dico di aprirla subito magari
qualcuno ha nascosto del cibo pronto per
essere scoperto da noi non pensa proprio
che qualcuno metà del cibo e non ha
scatenato scritto non aprire qui c'era
scritto non aprire se non in caso di
necessità e adesso non c'è più scritto
magari provò sbirciare dentro senza
aprire la scatola del tutto si fa
schiacciare allora
[Musica]
cosa c'è non vedo niente
come dire
effettivamente tutto buio
come sparito ma cosa stai dicendo
stai facendo uno scherzo niente qua
dentro
non mi stai facendo uno scherzo vero
prova ad aprirla aspetta che viene
soltanto che stai attento chi c'è ancora
ma allora innanzitutto è vero che non
c'è una bambola dentro fate le
confezioni di merendine vuote
che cosa significa sbagliato deve
rendere se possibile
c'era già chi qua dentro ma io proporrei
a stare dentro magari riescono interno
di nuovo mi è venuta un'idea che mi
voglio riaprire la scatola e vediamo
cosa trovo dentro un po di paura è pure
lo è io intanto cominciano allontanarmi
un po perchè sa oggi vediamo
ok sto visto che da qui però a debita
distanza per apparati a proteggermi ok
va bene prendo magica punti a testa se
c'è qualcuno mi ama la città si sta che
non fa nessun effetto momento appunto
splash non ha nessun povero magica lei
assalto di capello ma si chiamerà un
berlino in caso di bisogno perché non
voglio conoscerli non manderebbe la
scatola intera
anche questo è vero e come aveva già
tutto
chiusi di regia di floppy lo più
invitante di tutti non capisco ma se
meglio se provi a riaprirla tu ok va
bene provo adesso allora stai molto
attento
speriamo che questa volta ci siamo
veramente 20 mentre sei pronto ad
aprirla per la seconda prova allora si
esce si riesce a qualche altro cattivo
prendo lo butto direttamente jordan
no perché poi rincorrerà a me ho pensato
che a propriano così posso chiudere
subito una sbirciatina spazzatura è un
vasetto di yogurt alla fragola una busta
di patatine anche la mattina sono vuote
continuo a non capire cosa vuol dire
questa scatola proverò io per l'ultima
volta
ok a qualcuno che mi porterà tutto il
cibo che mi ha rubato
ok abbiamo un piano io aprirò molto
lentamente la scatola è vitale è pronto
mi sono attrezzato con la mazza così se
c'è qualcuno è così non si farà proprio
un bel niente
si spera paura stai attento però sesso
io ci personaggio buono non puoi
colpirlo no non c'è chi ce l'ha fatta
mi raccomando non colpire me colpirti
hanno tutte le ville a distanza che ben
si sa mai che stavolta mi allontano non
viene detto davanti
non posso cos'è giusto qualcosa hai
capito sono tanto le visto no vedo una
cosa nera che esce da libero papa ok
vado a controllare chiesto se io sono
sempre pronto qui
cos'è
sembra una giacchetta in miniatura per
le bambole paura non mi dire che quello
che sto pensando addio anche di un prima
e trovato delle mezze vuote
qualcuno è scappato lasciando solo la
giacca ma questa giacca sbaglio mi
ricorda qualcuno
tiffany quindi vuol dire che tiffany è
scappata dalla scatola una volta che lei
colpita ma perché dovevi colpire la
scatola con la è perché ho visto
muoversi ora è in giro per la casa e
chissà che cosa combinerà o no che ci
sbrighiamo troviamoci ok ok ma forse
prima dovremo capire che cosa significa
realmente questa scatola che cosa
significano parte delle bucce vuote che
qualcuno mi ha rubato il cibo e quindi è
una cosa negativa
certo che ero cosa negativa qualcuno si
mangia il mio cibo è una tua paura certo
che una mia paura se qualcuno mi ruba il
cibo potrebbe essere che nella scatola
compaiono le nostre paure per me sono
apparse le tre bambole cattive e perché
laggiù più grande paura e di avere cibo
sì qualcuno che ho appoggiato non è
giusto va beh non c'è tempo per pensare
adesso arriviamo a cercare tiffany e
cerchiamo di rinchiuderla nuovamente
dentro alla scatola altrimenti sarà un
disastro se la facciamo sparire vi
appariranno tutti e tutto il mio cibo
non penso proprio
allora per la tele prendere da zola
tifare ciao ciao
vuoi aiutarmi una bambola che attiva in
giro per la casa e tutte le voi
è mia amica sommato vado a mangiare
almeno ciao so io come convincere vitale
a tornare se mi aiuti a trovare tiffany
ti darò un gelato è detto gelato si sono
la stecca turiamo di bari però ok però
allora questo ti costerà due gelati
andiamo a trovarla più facilmente
dobbiamo separarci to controlla tutto il
piano di sotto e io controllerò tutto il
piano di sopra cioè questo piano dai
sbrigati
ok ragazzi non so da dove iniziare a
cercarla che cosa dovevo fare il cugino
mangiare certamente non può essere
andata lontana tiffany alle gambe
cortissime percorrete l'ultima volta che
abbiamo giocato a nascondino con tiffany
[Risate]
avete sentito cosa che verrà qua sparita
quindi è sicuramente qua dentro nello
studio forse è meglio se ha visto vitale
di venire qua ad aiutarmi
chissà cosa starà facendo adesso
chissà che cosa sta facendo in italia
[Musica]
controlliamo sotto al letto non so
perché ho l'impressione che ti fa che si
nasconda in luoghi molto bui sono caduti
dei pupazzi dal letto di sopra allora
sopra giove stare stifani c'e nessuno
qua vino si fa per aiutarmi
il mio fedelissimo aiutante berlino
cerca tiffany certa certa certa gioca
cerca velino cercava dove cercano
berlino sto cercando la sopra vuol dire
viene ancora là sopra cercato il vino
cerca e mi dove ma dove sarà finito
vitale non torna più vitale
ho bisogno del tuo aiuto berlino sta
cercando di salire lo stop quindi rete
definitivamente la sopra berlino non
puoi salire da qua ma che stai facendo
vuoi mangiare la matita o quindi in
realtà non aver rivisto schifani volevi
solo questa no basta non ha poi mangiare
merlino marino allontanati da quella
scatola è pericolosissimo chissà che
cosa uscirebbe fuori se berlino apprese
la scatola
degli ossì rosicchiati forse ho una
ciotola vuota di crocchette se tiffany
davvero sopra il letto io terrò la
scatola qui pronta così potrò buttargli
addosso e magari riesco a farlo
scomparire
berlino
[Musica]
bravissimo così non deve prima
scomparire trovato berlino bravissimo
trovarlo bravo non so che vorresti
finocchiaro ma si può saperlo è infinito
1 giu che controllavo suocera tifoni e
come mai questo parco di patatine e
mezzo vuoto
quindi mi stai dicendo che tuttavia il
piano di sotto non a mangiare le
patatine ma controllare no stavo
cercando l'arma del delitto in questo
caso praticamente c'era qualche bambolo
che è uscito dalla scatola di chi stava
mangiando le mie patatina è quindi io
sto controllando se effettivamente
questa è una prova a suo carico oppure
no non è vero l'unica bambola che uscita
dalla scatola e tiffany e se vuoi
saperlo merlino mi ha aiutato a trovarla
anzi l'ha trovata proprio lui sono
riuscit a rinchiuderla nella scatola o
merli non solo potendo non mi hai
aiutato proprio per ora stiamo
analizzando le
le prove la prova del delitto questa
scatola è molto pericolosa dobbiamo
chiuderla e nasconderla e non aprirla
mai chi usava sempre non deve essere mai
ritrovata dall'istituto e ci scriviamo
non aprite questa scatola ma qualcuno lo
aveva già scritto è solo che noi non ne
abbiamo prestato attenzione dove
potremmo nasconderla però riportiamo la
sua in soffitta così almeno lo troverà
più nessuno kg verrà messa in soffitta
però quando l'ho trovata io sì
portiamolo in soffitta e lascia molari e
chiudiamo la chiave e qui è esattamente
dove l'ho trovata proprio qua dobbiamo
lasciarla per sempre qua è troppo
pericolosa
[Musica]